four or five years ago for when Fox
approached me you're the only person in
the world can pull this off they got CDs
I began to think about it I actually I
said I'm on board after a month of
thinking I thought he's script wise I
got a crackdown this thing I think it's
important to have mature voice to exam
the story while we have a young man to
play pi so I thought of the older pilot
telling the story it's the same person
at the same time you can exam the value
of storytelling spirituality so I
thought I might get into the material
and I had a say thought four years ago
maybe by doing in 3d adding a dimension
maybe we can take a leap of faith I
didn't know what I was thinking about
but I just thought oh here's a water
movie without Tom Hanks I gotta do
something that's no to visualize the the
inner feeling whatever you what have you
so I thought of 3d did studies and it's
a long process it will take two hours to
explain Holly from beginning to end one
of the most important themes I think
overarching themes was the idea of
storytelling and that it wasn't just
about different faiths and different
religions and do you believe or not
believe it was not about trying to prove
whether or not there's a God it was
about the fact that stories and story
storytellers make sense of the chaos of
our lives and get us through the ordeals
in our lives and so with that as the
larger theme it had already come to the
conclusion he wanted to have that older
pie in there and that became the framing
device very naturally a bit of a
storyteller telling a story to a writer
who was then going to pass that on and
pass that on and and that other people
would take from it what they wanted I
spoke with and he you know had the idea
of how do we tell a story
with 3d and bringing someone forward for
just how do we feel about where they are
in space so we talked a lot or people
who reside and have a feeling and you
know sometimes Aang would say this gives
me a funny feeling and I go well let me
try to explore and try to either calm it
down or accentuate what that that
feeling is so and I did a test on you
know on the on the water and it just
waters is kind of a very unique thing
when it becomes in 3d I just feel like
it really kind of bends down forward and
really goes beyond and when you really
feel like he's in the middle of nothing
I really I feel like I see that a little
bit more 14% of the shots that you see
if there are real tiger the rest were
digital this is a chance I told my crew
I said you've got a tiger that's gonna
be a real tiger this is the best chance
you've ever had to try to fool your
colleagues and then pull off something
and make it as real as possible and I
know one of the big discussions that
that we had early in the production is
whether or not to use a real tiger and
that was an important question because
certainly if we have a real tiger there
our drop gets a lot harder but I think
for that very reason we chose to try to
use as much real Tigers as we could to
set the bar as high as we possibly could
and you know that it did it pushed the
team to do what hadn't been done before
and it also gave us the materials and
the stuff to study that we needed to put
all those tiny little nuances in the
tiger and make it what you saw out there
it was very important that it was a very
natural and organic thing like pi he
grows up in in a French colonial town in
India so he's already kind of in limbo
he's culturally he's a 21st century
person he didn't belongs everywhere in
nowhere so musically we wanted to have
those elements of French of Indian and
be able to kind of just you know toss
things back and forth effortlessly so we
have an English boys church choir
singing Sanskrit words and we have like
a Tibetan style choir singing in Latin
so we want as much as possible we tried
to blur lines and and and hopefully in a
way that's very easy to listen to and
and you know guide emotionally right
from you know the journey the physical
journey as well as the emotional journey
of the film well there's no
sixteen-year-old Indian movie star so we
got a go with fresh-faced that's pretty
obvious they get go
sir-sir is a it's a high schooler and in
Delhi I don't call him genius but he's
like Little Buddha like his last life is
a good actor that just sort of woke him
up I asked him to do the second story so
he did it and let's give him like a
one-minute directions
imagine the mother you're talking about
your own mother the sailors your brother
so and so for pretty basic method acting
thing
just reminded him and when we roll the
camera it's like his his whole body
every molecule is is in that story in
that situation as it's kind of
heartbreaking is when somebody take your
direction and just turning into a
character